l.a county restaurants halt
outdoor dining a three-week halt in
outdoor dining at restaurants wineries
breweries and bars and los angeles
county priests to go
set to go into effect wednesday night as
scheduled after boyd standing multiple
challenges today a superior court judge
ejected a motion
to block the ban and motion proposed at
the board of supervisors failed to
receive majority votes on tuesday
morning
a judge dismissed the challenge to debt
to health order et cetera et cetera
meaning restaurants are now shut down
for three weeks so the restaurant you
and i went to
with shonda and tom and tikrin yeah when
we went to
the place in manhattan very cool and we
ate a phenomenon outside right on the
deck and when we went and ate at rafi's
place outside
my favorite place both of those places
are officially shut down that's so fun
you can't do that that's so messed up
man
how do you handle that now i i i don't
understand what the plan
this is outdoor dining this is an indoor
dining yeah just to be super it's
outdoor dining why would outdoor dining
why would there be an issue with that is
there anything proven that outdoor
dining the whole point was to eat
outdoors right i can understand if
you're in minneapolis minnesota and it's
negative 10 degrees why you want to eat
outdoors if you're in manhattan beach
california
and it's 70 and sunny why you couldn't
be outdoors i just don't get it doesn't
add up this is
an overreach by government uh dictator
newsome
is clearly in garcetti your friends uh
this is
this this is a travesty and it really
actually really sucks
i think it's 12 shades of wrong which
i'm sure that surprises everybody
listening that's my take on it but uh
to me it just highlights again kind of
what we were talking about whether it's
guns whether it's drugs
you know whatever it is is that to me
you know
great freedom great responsibility is
that it should be up to you to decide
how you run your business
who you have over for thanksgiving all
of that stuff and it's across the board
you know if you want to wear a mask wear
a mask if you're that worried
you know that things are are that
dangerous for you then stay home i mean
between grubhub and doordash and
instacart and
ubereats and and everything else and
amazon you don't need to leave your
house
you know and if you're either at risk or
that that worried about it then stay
home
you know but to tell other people this
is how you're going to run your business
and again
it's always by people that aren't
running a business that aren't worried
about a bottom line that don't have
overhead or at least that matters that
you go
billions and billions into debt and it
doesn't mean anything you know and then
on top of that you have those guys
that aren't even adhering to the own
rules that they're putting in place
it leaves a horrible taste in
everybody's mouth it breeds resentment
against that stuff
and again it's just there's going to
come a tipping point and what i would
say
you know my last point with that is that
a lot of people kind of scoff at the you
know it's just a mask or it's just
two weeks to slow the spread or you know
nine months later it's just this it's
just that
to me everybody should should have a a
clear understanding of their own
personal constitution of when
when enough is enough and then also what
are you going to do about it
like have you ever thought is there a
point at which you're going to say you
know what no i'm not doing that
like is there an amount a time a
duration a
a level of restriction that the
government would put on you to where you
would say you know what [ __ ] you i'm not
doing it
damn is there one right is is there one
most people asking a question
is there one so give me a specific
example i'm saying
do you what is your boundary right like
people talk about you know psychology
boundaries are healthy
what is your your government boundary
where for you personally you're gonna
say you know what
not [ __ ] doing it yeah i don't know
if i have a specific example but i do
have libertarian tendencies like look
man
you know i'm going to do me you do you
i'm not going to tell you what to do i'm
not going to tell you how to
limit for that is there a limit where's
the the
the government can cross the line where
you're kind of like this is this is a
little too much for me
yeah i mean any bureaucratic [ __ ]
that i have to do
you know look it's all very complicated
out there whether you're
doing your taxes you're 401k you're
signing up for health shirts all the
paperwork and
it's just so freaking complicated just i
wish things were a little more simpler
and easier
so i tweeted this a couple days ago by
the way that's a very good question that
we can get into for 20 minutes i
sent this to newsome a couple days ago
go down
uh new some send out a message go up a
little bit more right there he said
uh covet update uh the last this last
week california is an unprecedented
rising cases average daily test uh
198 000 average test positive very 5.5
average daily test
uh case average 11 000 five in a
hospitalization up 70 70
77 ico 55 over the last two weeks and i
said
could it be due to a weak immune system
from a lack of exercise
could it be due to constantly selling
fear from the top maybe you ought to
think about opening up gyms and maybe
you ought to think about selling corp
what do you think gavin
and uh you know you hear the messaging
of so much the other day i did a video
on on
chronovirus and what i want to look is
what strengthens your immune system you
know what it said
mayo clinic said what strengthens your
immune system is exercising today
they're saying there's no link between
exercise and immune system
and webmd you know what webmd said there
is a
link between having a positive outlook
of the future
and your immune system wow so if
somebody's telling the future looks
bright things are going to be all right
we're going to be able to figure this
out your immune system gets stronger
versus somebody saying the end of the
world is around the corner all this
other stuff your immune system gets
weaker so the two things
yeah that we need to strengthen our
immune system is exercise
and selling hope is not being done by
this positive thinking
complete opposite is being sold by
california newsome and garcetti
the other thing so the immune system is
99.7
you know across the the entire spectrum
of the population is 99
effective at defeating the coronavirus
right the vaccines aren't that effective
so if you're putting that amount of
billions of dollars in time and research
and manpower and all this into vaccines
that are less effective than your immune
system
if the government is is so hell-bent joe
biden included on on handouts
then then why not distribute uh you know
a a a package to every individual that
you know from a vitamin supplement
standpoint helps
improve their their immune system the
same way why is there not some focus on
that there's there's none
you know so sleep exercise eat healthy
right yeah well i mean
eat healthy is is good you're on people
but you know can you tell the freaking
sun in addison texas to show up
there there is there is quantifiable
data
that shows vitamin and mineral
deficiency
as an in a direct relation to covid
kicking your ass
right so if you're deficient in vitamin
c vitamin d
magnesium things of that nature then
then your immune system is weak and it's
going to hand you to your ass a lot more
and those are very cheap easy easy
supplements to get a hold of
you